num ot the nummy thanks man
your big Magic the Gathering fan awesome
all right we're going Fred
defense against Conor rules one
apparently from Australia exchange
French
huh
upon d6
you
blocking in the sea pond
but my plan is going to be to put him
here and then Bishop here
maybe
not necessarily let's uh let's put this
night here
let me do something like this we'll see
yeah I thought you might do that
okay so that was their bad bishop but
it's still bishop
take with the queen probably show backed
up
I guess we'll trade
and
get my bishop out so this is just a
clean advantage for me bishop air
there's a
side structurally
what's up mad hand
throw a jab at the bishop
and how to move forward from here
hmm
all right let's let's bring this night
over here I don't think there's any
action on the queenside
this is something I would have done even
if the bishop wasn't there
and let's probably go here yeah
I think I want to just exchange 1 rook
so if they insist on trades and
just go to the D file maybe
completely symmetrical structure
the only difference here is this guy
versus the night
um let's jump in here he could probably
cause some problems
yeah night-night to d3 is looking a bit
more annoying though I guess I have to
be a little bit careful of Bishop c2
he's unprotected this this feels a lot
more laid-back
with the increment
what's my plan for Magnus if he shows up
to beat a man that's my plan
you
I didn't say it's going to be a
successful plan what's up Captain
Obvious are you playing I saw you uh-oh
yeah there you are you're in you're in
pause mode
yeah you already put up 45
that's a nice number
yeah thought you might do that
thanks for the 18 months in RL captain
I don't want to take that night
shoo
you
okay
um so what about now
hoes I exchanged rooks and then go here
or go here first
you
hmm
intended to turn
I don't know
move forward
yes I definitely will be taking breaks
okay this pawn is fixed so I mean if
they
end up doing something like taking out
my knight if they give me a true Bishop
pair one of my bishops will be able to
hunt down a minor piece I feel
just under a minute against Connor
Connor rules
that's
that's getting pretty serious huh
all right let's back up
I just don't want to play with them I
want to keep this kind of structure so I
feel that I'm getting a little something
now and playing against the isolated
pawn
this is really a wonderful night night
here is no bother my pawn controls the
night
yeah and I'm definitely feeling like I
want to keep the rook on if they
challenge me something like this isn't
out of the question
go forward
initial thought was here but I don't
need to guard this I need to guard this
and I know I'm stopping rook here so I
might want to
slowly no I don't want to touch him I
don't want to give her this square up so
he's going nowhere
kind of stuff isn't out of the question
and the other thing is why didn't I
maybe throw my rock on e to first let's
do that right now
a lot of pieces hitting here but I don't
think any anything is working
you
I don't know let's just step up one more
I don't want to do this because I gave
up this square
it's kind of on a I think I just want to
sit
maybe now I could flush the night away
oh yeah actually now there's a tactic I
think
I chased the night away and then I have
this because he's in a pin
I think I could end up winning upon
move check Oh actually the check the
King can't go here to counter-attack my
rook
so now that this is a big issue
and I could just take them
and I'm going into pac-man mode
you
I didn't see that they moved
let's just give a check
feel like I could give me I don't need
to take the rook I'm threatening what am
i doing
they could have captured my night it's
getting too fancy
I had two different main threats I'm
like I don't see how they stop both made
threats yeah they could have captured
your night there
[Laughter]
this is a pretty fun game this this
chess
you